[Music]
oh blackout
oh
[Music]
sorry buddy everything's okay
excuse me we did not order a poltergeist
um if this is the pizza guy this is
really unprofessional
foreign
[Music]
hello
jog
I don't know how you got back but you
made a big mistake coming here oh
contraire Mo frere
steak was thinking you'd won
an hors d'oeuvre
teeth and a moves Bush I get it
I don't think you do
it's about to
so will that idiot sheriff in his wife
and your little dog
[Music]
[Music]
who are you
where
are my manners
Sonic meat Knuckles my new bffae
bestest friend forever and ever
look Robotnik I don't care who you
brought to help you you're never going
to get my power do I look like I need
your power
[Music]
thank you
it's so nice when diabolical evil lives
up to the height
[Music]
where is it oh you want it
it comes I was expecting more of you
you're unskilled I am afraid
and unworthy
Unstoppable
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
it's my destiny to do what my ancestors
could not to restore the ultimate power
to the home of my people
ultimate power I don't know what you're
talking about
you've got the wrong guy ultimate power
by language
don't play dumb with me Apprentice of
long claw you knew long claw long her
people were the sworn Enemy of My Tribe
the Echidna we fought and died at their
hands and now you
died
come on get in I'm on your side I'm
sorry who are you
you know what it doesn't matter
who's out of here
oh he's got Robin gross
egg man
[Music]
wow okay let say it is an honor to
finally meet you Sonic is it okay if I
call you Sonic everyone calls me Tails
you're probably wondering why let me
guess because of the extra tail that's
right I should have known you'd get that
cool also what is going on robotnik's
back and who is Clifford The Big Red
Rage monster that's Knuckles the last of
the echidnas and the most dangerous
warrior in the Galaxy he's obsessed with
finding the Master Emerald are you
serious from Master Emerald that's just
a bedtime story well he believes it's
real and he must think you're the key to
finding it
all right
like a whale
I think we lost him
we should definitely did not lose him
I have an idea do you trust me of course
not I literally just met you what are
you doing
haha
ah we're flying uh did your butt just
turn into a helicopter
a quadcopter oh only Sonic the Hedgehog
could come up with something like that
oh
foxy moves
I want something done right
you have to hire someone you can push
around
these Rings signify the commitment
sorry sorry
right now
snow my god oh boy
ah Hawaii it's just so weird not too
late oh Lord there are two of them now
what's happening okay quick version
Robotnik is back
I discovered the source of ultimate
power
we need to get it back before the world
is Doom
you brought some kind of
space porcupine I am an Echidna Warrior
hmm
Hedgehog It's Time to Say Goodbye to
humanity
this is your moment to be the big hero
bad time to say this but I don't
actually have a plan
hey you got a little something on your
uh someone call an Uber it's cold in
here let's turn up the heat
foreign
yeah
you forgot one
Unstoppable
[Music]
for a guy named Knuckles you are really
bad at punching
[Music]